[Musique]
il s'appelait artiste léoniday mais il
était connu dans le rap US sous le nom
de Coolio
[Musique]
c'est en 1995 que cet artiste va se
révéler au monde entier grâce à son tube
gangsta Paradise musique du générique du
film esprit rebelle
[Musique]
ces textes engagés savoir au coulio
secret très vite une identité alors
décrocher plusieurs petits rôles dans
des blockbusters américains comme Scary
Movie ou encore Batman et Robin
durant trois ans il va être en couple
avec l'exta du loft Afida Turner il
participera d'ailleurs lui-même à la
version américaine Big Brother
[Musique]
mercredi à l'âge de 59 ans le rappeur
s'est éteint ce soir Afida Turner a
décidé de lui rendre hommage dans TPMP
people
voilà Coolio et je rappelle donc Coolio
était il était justement de 59 ans et
jeudi soir il était découvert mort dans
sa salle de bain la salle de bain d'un
ami pardon à Los Angeles personne ne
sait me rapporte toxicologique qui a été
fait mais pour l'instant on n'a pas
encore les les données donc on sait pas
du tout s'il y avait de la drogue de
l'alcool on ne sait pas du tout est-ce
que tu en sais un peu plus d'alcool il
buvait pas
dans une dépression un petit peu d'avoir
été laissé par le métier de de ne pas
retrouver le succès c'est vrai ça
très difficile d'avoir un
skip
avant gangsta Paradise s'il avait déjà
fait trois albums bien avant avec
Matthia coramine beaucoup de beaucoup de
CD qui ont été fait auparavant et que en
dans les années 90 gangs ça Paradise
avec Michel Pfeiffer est devenu numéro 1
avec dangerous mind et après ça il
décide de revenir avec un titre aussi
fort et c'était très compliqué pour lui
ça marchait pas mais tu crois pas que du
coup cette dépression ça marchait il a
toujours tourné il faut savoir que c'est
un garçon un homme qui a toujours tourné
depuis 93 jusque 2022 likes des parties
en Allemagne avant le passeport il a
toujours
l'Allemagne l'Angleterre le Japon
l'Hollande un peu la France mais dans
tous les pays il a toujours été bouquet
du du mardi au dimanche
fort et il y a eu d'autres tripes titres
bien évidemment ce qui m'intéresse c'est
quand est-ce que tu as appris sa mort tu
étais où
je me suis levé avant de chair à 5h du
matin mais c'était comme c'était comme
si je suis désolé je suis pas la même la
même personne aujourd'hui j'ai du mal à
prononcer mes mots
c'est à dire que la journée avant avant
j'avais une sorte de
prémunition j'ai dit aujourd'hui je fais
pas de sport je bosse pas on est
descendu aux Marignan avec un ami
mourir non j'arrêtais pas de penser à
lui pendant trois quatre jours et je dis
aujourd'hui je fais rien je descends au
Marignan et effectivement on a bu une
bouteille de vin rouge et fumé deux
cigarettes qui est très rare et j'étais
en stress et je me suis réveillé à 5h du
matin avec un mal de crâne et j'ouvre
mon portable je reçois un message de loy
Klein qui est c'est comme un frère qui a
Miami il me dit désolé for you lost mes
condoléances
à love your Mindel i'm so sorry et là il
met pas le nom de la personne
à 59 ans c'était la hutline qui m'a
annoncé
c'était mon ex mon ex-fiancé
en 2002-2003 on est resté ensemble
pendant trois ans c'est quelqu'un qui
avait une vie assez mouvementée donc moi
j'ai voulu pas trop me désorienter avoir
une life salle un peu plus correcte donc
j'ai cassé avec lui mais à chaque fois
il revenait et il revenait toujours
genre le jour de mon anniversaire ou à
Noël avec des fleurs juniors et je
reparte avec lui
aussi qu'on le retrouve dans une salle
de bain il était peut-être un peu
Rockstar on va dire Rockstar il
voyageait tout le temps et puis bon il
était avec nous on va continuer de
parler de Coolio qu'on adorait qu'elle a
une énorme YouTube et j'ignorais
totalement que tu avais de tes 3 ans
avec lui et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
était très touchés moi maquiller plus
Turner
qui tremblent le corps qui tremble parce
que avec nous aujourd'hui pour parler de
la mort de Coolio vous venez de
l'entendre ce rappeur qui avait eu un
tube gigantesque et c'est vrai qu'afida
nous a confié qu'elle est sortie avec
Julio pendant deux ou trois ans je crois
et d'ailleurs on a une image de toi
affidage j'espère que ça a pas trop de
toucher mais tu avais fait l'émission de
terre Ardisson tout mon en parle et vous
vous étiez embrassé langoureusement dans
l'émission rappelle-toi oui oui je me
souviens ouais
je suis féminine mais super masculine et
c'est vrai que j'avais envie j'en ai
marre de toujours tout contrôler dirigé
j'ai envie d'un homme un vrai alors un
jour vous êtes en studio à Los Angeles
et puis il y a quelqu'un qui vous
demande s'il peut écouter vos maquettes
et puis c'est Coolio voilà miracle
miracle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
Coolio success mondial avec gangsta
Paradise
forcément c'est dur de revoir ces images
comme ça c'était à quelques années ça
c'est
en fin 2003 début 2004 mais on a
toujours on s'est vu la dernière fois au
mois de mai c'est la dernière fois que
j'ai vu en fait donc juin juillet ouais
ça fait 4 mois quasiment c'était
une des plus belles histoires de d'amour
de ma vie voilà et pourquoi vous êtes
séparés
je me suis séparée mais lui c'est pas
séparé c'est à dire que pendant on est
resté ensemble pendant trois ans mais
pendant quasiment un an et demi on
continuait moi je disais non c'est
terminé over
on continue à chaque fois et puis
parce que c'est une rockstar il est un
homme très animal et très dominant donc
un jour il est au Japon le lendemain il
était en Suisse lendemain il était en
Hollande et c'est un homme qui aime
beaucoup les femmes
qui aime beaucoup les femmes voulu
divine oui bah c'est un homme qui aime
beaucoup les femmes moi je voulais
savoir Afida et j'ai beaucoup de
beaucoup de peine et de tendresse pour
vous parce que j'imagine que c'est
douloureuse que vous vivez mais je
voulais savoir si les raisons qui vous
avez motivé à l'époque j'avais revu chez
Ardisson deux trois ans après il était
venu en disant oui elle est crazy et moi
aussi et donc les tempéraments ça match
pas
besoin d'un mec qui était un bouffon qui
ferme sa gueule parce que mes femmes
doivent se taire et exécuter tout ce que
je dis i am the boss et ça je l'ai vu
vous savez quoi tu sais quoi je l'ai vu
hier parce que hashtag et j'avais pas vu
quand il était avec un gros italien
exactement ah et j'ai eu peur j'ai ce
qui veut dire des choses
visiblement ça a été quand même aussi
quelqu'un de violent parce qu'il a été
arrêté avait par rapport à son ex-femme
qu'il avait un petit peu tapé je voulais
savoir si les raisons qui vous avez
motivé à partir à l'époque c'était des
violences domestiques par rapport à
Julio non il a jamais il a jamais mis un
coup de poing ou te tirer les cheveux
comme ça après il y a des intercations
c'est quelqu'un très intense moi j'étais
très intense
quand même
ça devait partir un petit peu dans les
tours
je vais un peu mieux là je suis désolé
tout à l'heure j'étais en Tremblade
j'avais perdu ma voix et mon élocution
Amba catika
je peux parler c'est bien oui c'était
quelqu'un de très intense mais c'est pas
c'est pas un mec qui tabasse des femmes
ah ben oui il est sur son ex quand même
donc il avait non seulement tapé mais
rouler en voiture
sur les images on le voit arriver avec
une coupe de champagne on peut imaginer
que pour moi quand on est un rappeur
quand voilà tu l'as dit toi-même qu'il
avait un certain une vie un peu
mouvementée il me prenait aucune
substance rien il était complètement
il a eu des addictions et que pour
arrêter ces addictions il a fait quelque
chose de très noble c'est à dire qu'il a
été stoppé les feux dans dans les
vallées de San Francisco pendant deux
ans pour se réhabiliter et c'est comme
ça qui sait
concentré et écrit c'est fantastique hit
oui bon il le dit qu'il prend des des
qui prend des choses c'est connu mais
par respect pour son image et pour pour
sa disparition et pour sa famille je ne
rentrerai pas dans des dans des
histoires toxiques d'accord dernière
question
vous êtes qui vous je vous connaissez
quel est
votre bébé
[Applaudissements]
je te dis tout elle est bandeau chez
arabes on avait on avait un trou dans
l'émission on avait un trou dans
l'émission
j'adore cette question vous êtes qui
non je vous ai jamais vu en disant de on
ne sait jamais vu d'accord mais vous
m'avez vu aujourd'hui alors vous avez
des émissions culturelles
tu te présentes avant de poser ta
question on sait jamais croisé parce
qu'avant je faisais des émissions
extrêmement culturelles d'accord
[Rires]
la question c'est vous n'avez jamais
envie de faire un enfant avec lui parce
que il a tellement enfin on a
l'impression qu'il a la patate cet
homme-là pardon on a l'impression qu'il
a la paternité
c'est un garçon très sexuel et très
active non mais on peut être très sexuel
sans faire des enfants
c'était une séquence hommage c'était une
séquence mais toi tu ne voulais pas
d'enfant avec pardon tu ne voulais pas
d'enfant avec toi j'ai fait plusieurs
fausses couches ah c'est vrai la
question était très bien quelqu'un
d'autre m'insulter à FIDA oui bah une
petite question pour Afida parce que
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui non je vais
être gentil mais c'est vrai que qui
es-tu déjà qui es-tu Floriane et il y a
beaucoup de rappeurs ces dernières
années comme on le publique il connaît
pas tous mais DMX Nate dog qui sont tous
très bien parce que ils ont pas quand
même tendance un peu à brûler la vie
parler debout
c'est ça qu'on a perdu
Rockstar qui boit du thé vert
ils sont vieux c'est est-ce qu'il y a 59
ans quand on est retrouvé dans une salle
de bain est-ce que ça a pas un lien
qu'on se le dis c'est exactement et ben
on aura la réponse mercredi voilà je
pense qu'elle sera assez positive tu as
raison et pour autant ça dans la vraie à
son talent oui dernière question
pourquoi pas autre chose on se dit
pardon quand on lit dans la presse on se
dit quasiment une tradition chez les
rappeurs et c'est incroyable c'est
acceptation qu'on a du fait que bah oui
disparaissent les uns et ben c'est une
star bébé c'est une star bébé tu avais
qu'à faire une chanson merci dans tous
les cas d'être venu c'est très très
gentil et le temps de